"SATURDAY SESSION."
THAT AND MORE IS AHEAD.
>>> FIRST, THERE ARE NEW SIGNS
THIS MORNING THAT SHOW THE U.S.
ECONOMY IS STILL STRUGGLING FROM
THE SEISMIC IMPACT OF THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC SHUTDOWN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND EVEN
INVESTORS ON WALL STREET TRIED
TO PUSH PAST FRIDAY'S
DISAPPOINTING REPORT FROM THE
LABOR DEPARTMENT.
IT SHOWED THE SLOW EVER MONTHLY
JOBS GROWTH YET SINCE MR. BIDEN
TOOK OFFICE.
THE LACKLUSTER NEWS IS LEAD
SOMETHING BUSINESS GROUPS AND
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS TO MAKE THE
CASE TO END ENHANCED FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS THAT THEY
SAY ARE ENCOURAGING AMERICANS
NOT TO WORK.
R
CHRISTINA RUFFINI IS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
SUCCESS IS RARELY A STRAIGHT
LINE, AND NEITHER IS ECONOMIC
RECOVERY.
THAT'S WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
ARGUING ON THE HEELS OF THAT
DISAPPOINTING JOBS REPORT.
ARMED WITH A MIX OF ECONOMIC
METAPHORS --
>> THE ROAD BACK IS GOING TO BE
SOMEWHAT BUMPY.
>> WE HAVE --
>> Reporter: THE WHITE HOUSE
WENT ON THE DEFENSIVE YESTERDAY
AFTER THE LOWEST MONTHLY JOBS
REPORT SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN
TOOK OFFICE.
>> WE KNEW THIS WOULDN'T BE A
SPRINT, IT WOULD BE A MARATHON.
>> Reporter: EMPLOYERS ADDED
JUST 266,000 JOBS IN APRIL.
DRAMATICALLY LESS THAN THE
MILLION MOST ECONOMISTS HAD
PROJECTED.
THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE TICKED
SLIGHTLY UP TO 6.1%.
>> DATA SHOWS THAT MORE WORKERS,
MORE WORKERS ARE LOOKING FOR
JOBS, AND MANY CAN'T FIND THEM.
>> Reporter: BUT REPUBLICANS
ARGUE THE $300 PER WEEK
UNEMPLOYMENT CHECKS ARE KEEPING
PEOPLE FROM WORKING.
>> THEY ARE BETTER OFF TO STAY
HOME RATHER THAN GO BACK TO
WORK.
>> Reporter: THE U.S. CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IS CALLING FOR A REPEAL
OF SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS, AND
TWO REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS SAY
THEY PLAN TO BLOCK THOSE CHECKS
IN AN EFFORT TO BOOST JOB
NUMBERS.
TREASURY SECRETARY JANET YELLEN
SAID UNPREDICTABLE CHILDCARE AND
LINGERING COVID CONCERNS ARE
MORE LIKELY CULPRITS.
>> IT'S CLEAR THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT READY AND
ABLE TO GO BACK INTO THE LABOR
FORCE.
>> Reporter: THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY SHOWED THE BIGGEST
GAINS IN THE APRIL REPORT.
BUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
RESTAURANTS LIKE THIS OAKLAND
EATERY ARE STRUGGLING TO REFILL
THEIR STAFF.
>> EVERYONE I HIRE, I TELL THEM
YOU HAVE TO WEAR A LOT OF HATS
NOW.
THE SUPPORT TEAM THAT WE USED TO
HAVE PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC ISN'T
QUITE THERE.
>> Reporter: CBS NEWS BUSINESS
ANALYST JILL SCHLESINGER SAYS
THERE'S A STRAIGHTFORWARD
SOLUTION.
>> IF SOMEBODY CAN MAKE MORE
MONEY BY BEING HOME AND
COLLECTING UNEMPLOYMENT AND
TAKING CARE OF THEIR FAMILIES,
THAT'S A SMART ECONOMIC
DECISION.
AND IT MAY FORCE RESTAURANTS AND
SOME OF THE OTHER AREAS OF THE
ECONOMY TO REALLY PICK UP THE
WAGES.
>> Reporter: NOW DURING THE
GREAT DEPRESSION, THERE WAS A
PROMINENT BRITISH ECONOMIST WHO
ARGUED THAT THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD PAY PEOPLE TO DIG HOLES
AND FILL THEM BACK UP AGAIN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN ISN'T GOING THAT
FAR BUT IS PITCHING HIS
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AS A WAY TO
FILL THE JOBS GAP.
NEXT WEEK HE WILL MEET AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH REPUBLICANS
HOPING THEY CAN FIND SOME
POLITICAL